In order to calculate the answer to this question,
instead of doing it by hand, I'm going to let Python do the work.
What I've done is I've collected together the data from the question,
the total time of the round trip for the data, which was 75 milliseconds,
the one-way distance, which was 2,500 kilometers, the speed of light in an optic fiber,
which is 200,000 km/sec.
Note that this is kilometers per second, but the total time is in milliseconds,
which means I'm going to need a conversion between milliseconds and seconds.
Let's think. What do I need to calculate?
Well, what I want to know is the totaltimeat_routers.
Working backwards from what I want to know, let's see what I need to calculate.
Well, the total time spent at the routers is equal to the total_time minus the timeonthe_wires.
How am I going to calculate the timeonthe_wires?
That's while it's in the fiber optics rather than actually at the routers.
The time on the wires--that's equal to--well, how do we calculate time
when we've got distances and speed?
Well, it's simply distance divided by speed.
Now, what distance are we using?
Well, the total timeatthe_routers is equal to total_time.
That's actually the time for the round trip, so we need to know how long the data
was on the fiber optics for the round trip, which means we need to go twice the distance.
That's the one-way distance.
We're going to divide by the speed that the data is traveling in the wires,
which is the optical speed.
Now at the moment, we've got--what have we got here?
We've got kilometers divided by km/sec, which is going to give us an answer in seconds.
But our times are measured in milliseconds, so that's seconds at the moment,
and we want to convert it into milliseconds.
We have to multiply it by the number of milliseconds per second.
That's our conversion factor, which is milliseconds per second.
Let's see what happens--75.
That's a bit weird, isn't it? Because the total time was 75.
What's gone wrong?
Let me just print out here the timeonthe_wires--0.
Well, that doesn't make sense, does it?
Because it's been somewhere, and it's come back--it can't have taken 0 time.
What's the problem here?
Well, the problem is this division.
What we have in Python--at least before version 3--is that division is integer division.
So if the number is less than 1, which it will be here,
because onewaydistance is only 2,500, and we're dividing by 200,000.
Python just rounds it down to the nearest integer, which is 0.
In order to deal with that, I'm just going to make it into a float,
which means that it does division normally and gives an answer which is a decimal.
You can convert all of these into floats, but really we just need to do one of them.
If I run it now, I find that the first value here--25--is the amount of time on the wires,
and the totaltimeat_routers is 50 milliseconds.
You need to be a little bit careful to make sure that you're doing float division.
Float is just decimal division instead of integer division.